uh 617-830-4750
let's go next to thomas thomas who we've
heard from before what's going on thomas
hi david um thanks for having me yeah
i uh i was uh watching
uh some of the hearing yesterday about
uh the rise of white nationalism in the
united states
yep i felt really bad for some of the
people there who had
actual concerns and they had to take a
back seat to candice owens's
i know asinine statements disgusting
and i know um here's the thing that i've
been noticing about her supporters
though they seem to
sort of not understand the grasp that
nationalism can be radicalized to where
it can hurt other people they seem to
think that like once
a leader who's nationalistic decides to
hurt his own
his or her own citizens and it stops
becoming nationalism
which yeah well listen the problem is
even bigger than that honestly tom i
mean you're pointing out something
that's true which is there's a lack of
understanding about when we're talk
people there are people who benignly put
nationalism
in the same camp as sort of just like
being patriotic and as you're pointing
out
that that's just not accurate and if you
truly understand
what national nationalism is and how it
can
be weaponized uh you wouldn't be playing
so coy with it not you thomas i mean but
the people who are
uh but the the fact that the most
important discussions that should be had
didn't happen really at those hearings
at least in part
in part because of people like candace
owens i mean it's just it's it's
disgusting and i congratulate
congressman ted lou
for playing her her hitler comment
during the uh testimony i think that was
absolutely brilliant oh oh speaking of
that um
i see people like saying like oh you
took her out of context or whatever
and they share this meme with like
her whole response and text and and
people are making the same uh judgment
saying like you know that doesn't help
her
you posting all that text that verbatim
text of what she said
no it makes it worse and you know what
the other thing is ted
she she responded in the moment with
something like by playing that clip
ted lou is implying he thinks black
people are too stupid to figure out the
context around what she said
she's playing the race card that she
says should not be played
who ted lou did nothing having to do
with black people he just played a clip
you know
and if i can make one more point yeah
she's uh she's at a at a conference
and the question she was talking about
the question she was answering was
uh having to do with the uh the concept
of nationalism
and i'm like you're gonna you're gonna
talk about nationalism
and the first thing you want to bring up
is uh
the the first thing you want to bring up
is hitler right you're talking about
that
and i'm like uh why would you even
bother to bring that up i'm pretty sure
there are like other people out there
who
use nationalist policies that have
benefited their own people
sure yeah right like if you're trying to
make the case if you're trying to make
the
case that nationalism is is relatively
benign and or a good thing
then maybe go to someone whose
nationalism didn't involve the
extermination of the jews you know
yeah and it's just i
that that's that's where i went off on
my whole uh tangent of that
about there being different levels of
nationalism don't bring up the guy who
used his nationalism aka patriotism to
justify killing his own citizenship
right
the worst example of nationalism i'm
really hoping
i i'm really hoping uh kansas hears this
to just
really learn how stupid her comments
were and why people are
calling her stupid for making those
comments yeah i don't know that she's
lev
capable of that sort of degree of
self-reflection but i appreciate the
thoughts thomas
thank you very much dave all right i
think thomas and i may have been on a
slight delay there
one of today's david pakman show
sponsors is chevome which provides
genetic testing products with the
mission of keeping everybody's personal
genetic data totally private making sure
that no personal identifying information
gets attached
to your genetic data when it is stored
in their database
medical researchers can benefit from
chavon's pool of genetic data but unlike
a lot
of other genetic testing companies
shavom ensures that
no third parties are able to link you
personally with your genetic data and
shavom actually
incentivizes customers for making their
anonymized genetic data available to
medical researchers
if you opt in to allowing your genetic
data to be used
for health research you'll receive
vouchers for other genetics
services that shavom offers shavom
is proud to announce that they are now
partnering with family care
path at the cleveland clinic to
integrate their genetic testing
resources
with chevome's marketplace of services
you can check out shavome by going to
shavom.io